[موسيقى]
حقيقه هذا الامر اللي هو السجال الطائفي
والعقائدي يظهر باوضح صوره حينما نتحدث عن
شخصيات معاويه بن ابي سفيان وعن الدوله
الامويه ايضا يعني اعطيك مثال يكفيك الان
ان تقول اسم معاويه فقط دون ان تتكلم شيئا
انت لم تقل اي شيء قلت بس فقط اسم معاويه
فجاه يشتعل السجال والجدال والاخذ والرد
وبين محب وكاره وفي كل مكان
حتى تيك توك يا جماعه انا لسه ما قلت شيء
يعني لسه المسلسل ما عرض لم يعرض المسلسل
ولم يعرف احدا ماذا يتكلم اشتعل الجدل
والسجاد هذا هو صوره من صور
المواقف المسبقه والمغلقه تجاه احداث
التاريخ او حتى احداث الحياتيه اليوميه
هذا هذا السجال الطائفي تسبب في يعني يعني
ظلم معرفي وحجب عنا الاطلاع الثقافي
والثراء المعرفي الواسع الذي ممكن ان
نستلهمه من دراسه ومعرفه شخصيه معاويه بن
ابي سفيان
[موسيقى]
حوارنا لكن انت الجدل هذا اللي دار هل هو
منطلق ديني عقائدي ولا سياسي كما يرى
الباحث
انا اعتقد انه في مثل هذه المسائل يختلط
الامرين لسياسه بالدين والسياسي والعقائدي
والطائفي والديني والثقافي مساله مركبه
ومعقده والحقيقه يعني كثير من الافكار
والاتجاهات هي تبدا في البدايه من منطلقات
سياسيه تبدا من منطلقات السياسيه ثم مع
مرور الوقت تتحول الى عقائد وهذا يعني جزء
كبير من تشكل الفرق والطوائف والمذاهب في
الاسلام في بدايتها كانت لاسباب سياسيه
وبعد ذلك تحولت الى جوانب عقائديه لكن في
جزء من هذا السجال ليس المقصود هو الشخصيه
التاريخيه القديمه حين هذا السجال الطائفي
الذي يغلف بانه صناعه علاج شخصيه تاريخيه
هو ليس من اجل الشخصيه التاريخيه
[موسيقى]